hello everyone the European Team
Championship is currently being played
in Greece and this was a very
interesting game from round three I was
played between Yana Pony Oishi and the
fourth highest rated check a chess
grandmaster victrolas Nika and it's
quite an interesting game like in that
game I did about two days ago I believe
in Jobar versus Barea Jabbar gave Maria
a choice whether he will recapture with
the pawn or with the night and while
although recapturing would the night was
a better move Burrell decided to capture
with the pawn and his position fell
apart similar is also in this game but
let's see it so neppo has the white
pieces and he plays efore we have c6 by
Viktor the caro-kann defense d4 d5 and E
5 the advance variation of the caro-kann
Bishop to f5 Knight to f3 d6 Bishop to
e2 c5 now Bishop to e3
C captures Knight captures and the
knight to e7 and black is kind of given
up the bishop pair here if nipple would
capture Knight captures an f5 but then
this night would get this beautiful
square and f5 and he would be a very
powerful piece there so nappa simply
kept castles we have Knight B to c6
Bishop to b5 pinning the night we have a
6 Bishop captures B captures and we have
c4 Queen to d7 now defending the c6
Banda was attacked Knight to c3 and we
have B captures on c4 some other moves
were also possible here for example rook
to b8 maybe even c5 or Bishop to g6 but
okay Victor played D captures on c4 and
we have Knight to a4 and here in empo is
threatening night to b6 with a fork
forking the rook and the Queen we have
Knight to d5 and this is a yeah I mean
it's also kind of a waiting game move
because nappa doesn't want to capture
this Bishop on fi
but he doesn't want to capture it while
this night is an e7 so now after he
played Knight to a4 to threaten the
night to b6 fork Viktor defense with
Knights to d5 now getting ready to
develop this bishop now the bishop is
also protecting c5 and the night from d5
is protecting b6 so now that the night
is gone from e7 neppo captures the
Bishop to Knight captures on f5 we have
it captures on f5 and rook to c1 and
okay he's threatening to capture this c4
pawn you can't really defend this pawn
better would be to simply play Bishop to
e7 and castle and completely forget
about this pawn but Victor plays c3 kind
of mess up Nepos plans capturing the
pawn with the knight is perfectly fine
but never plays the Queen to c2 and here
probably capturing with C capture some
b2 was okay also rook to b8 was fine but
the Victor now plays Bishop to d7 and
Napo recaptures with knife capture since
e3 we have Knight captures on e3 now
grabbing the dark square bishop and
doubling up white spawns F captures on
e3 Bishop to g5 now with the threat of
Bishop captures and ether we would check
for King the king and the rook rook seat
the e1 defending and we have g6 and well
these dark squares are really really
weak now this f1 became quite a target
and the Napo makes use of this he plays
g4 we have F captures on g4 and now
Knight to e4 Bishop to e7 rook to d1 now
with the tempo on the Queen Queen to c8
and here we have a very interesting move
well night the c5 would have been
perfectly fine and it would give an F of
the advantage but neppo decided to go
for the for the insta-kill and he played
east six and this is the moment i was
talking about that it's similar to the
joe bob array of game now victor can
capture with Queen captures on e6 and
also with F captures a nice
in the game he capture F captures and he
six was played which was a terrible
terrible blunder but before I show you
what happened in the game let's just
check what happens if Queen captures on
e6 and it doesn't seem like that part of
a variation to calculate so I wonder why
Viktor decided not to go for this maybe
it was time trouble I don't really have
the details of this game but after Queen
captures on e6
there is Knight to d6 with check and
well you definitely don't want to go to
the D file in front of the rook if you
play something like King to f8 you get
rook captures on f7 would check white
wins the Queen and after Knight to d6
check if you play something like Bishop
captures and e6 you get Queen captures
on c6 with check and also well if you
defend with the Queen you lose the rook
on a8 so King t7 would have to be played
and now the rooks are connected but rook
captures on d6 and after Queen captures
Queen - b7 check Queen blocks and now
rook captures on f7 King captures and
now Queen captures on d7 with check and
well white does have a queen and this g4
pawn is definitely gonna fall the black
rooks are undeveloped but I I don't I
don't think that it's that easy to win
this with white if at all possible so
it's I'm curious why Victor didn't go
for this so if any of you have some more
details about this game feel free to
share in the comments as well Teresa
--kx
Victor played F captures an e6 and
disallowed nipple well a very our a very
quick kill with Queen to c3 and there
are simply too many threats here the
Queen of course the main threat is Queen
captures an h8 grabbing the rook this
was this was avoided with rook to f8
robbed the g8 might have been a bit more
resilient but it wouldn't really have
helped black rook to f8 rook captures
and I faith would check Bishop captures
and f8 was played if King captures on f8
also losses with the Queen to h8 check
King to f7 and now rook the f1 check and
after Bishop blocks rook captures King
to e7 now Queen g7 check King has to go
to d8 and rook the faith with checkmate
so at rook actors on f8 Bishop captures
and f8 was played and here nepo played
Queen to h8 and the victrolas Nita
resigned the game there are like I said
too many threats here black cannot avoid
them all let's just see if a black for
example plays Queen to c7 Knight d6
check wins the game immediately black
has to give up the Queen with Queen
captures if you play something like King
2d a torque in 37 night to c5 check a
discovered check from the rook wins the
Queen and if you play a move like King
to e7 you get Queen 2h7 check you do
have to move came to f6 and now you grab
the Queen if you go to d8 it's it's the
same night nice to be 5 with check I
discover check from the rook also wins
the Queen so none of this was played
after Queen to h8 Victrola snitch go
resign in the game and although all the
all the titles on the web pages and some
blogs said a beautiful miniature by nepo
it is 26 moves this Queen 288 is the 26
moves so I don't believe it classifies
as a miniature I believe a miniature is
25 moves or or less but I could be wrong
you know it's been known to happen
so yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Jeremy
Newhouse Rahman Allah wise and Rodrigo
Carvalho for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I'll see you soon